[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the lobby
you GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco California I'm
your host Mike McCarty here as always we
reviews editor Peter Brown you made a
weird noise during our intro and I just
keeps doing it and that's awful that's
Rob doing Rob Henry what's going on
what's up how's it going it's going good
dude thanks yeah you've been playing
lawbreakers lately we talked about that
we've all been getting our butts kicked
in law breakers but I found out there's
a good yeah you have to there's a class
I really like that I've been playing
we're gonna talk more about that we're
gonna talk about yakusoku ami Kelley
plag you've been playing hell-blade
along with a few of us got a lot to talk
about with that game yeah we'll get into
that soon as always we have some news
stories and we have a giveaway which
I'll announce later around the show
toward the end Chivo will tweet it out
from our GameSpot account if you don't
follow us right now if you're watching
this on Twitch or YouTube or GameSpot go
follow us on Twitter
later on there be a giveaway tweet you
can retweet it later on the week we'll
pick a random few random winners sorry
spoiled what it was yeah whoever you
have the best name's Reggie Mickey
Crenshaw cool
so as everybody knows now first off
shadow war has ranked multiplayer
fortress assault which sounds kind of
cool it's like the Forward Operating
Base from Metal Gear Solid 5 okay like
yeah so you uh you can opt into it you
can say you know you build up your
fortress as a big part of this game
there's a strategy layer of kind of
controlling Mordor in the outer lying
regions you have like ask Ilyas I mean
it's more gold ministereth or sorry not
me to earth like curious long ago all
these different fortresses but now you
can install other peoples in this like
ranked matchmaking what do we all say
like mode so then you can actually build
up your fortresses to defend them but I
guess in bigger news the thing that's
kind of pissing a lot of people off is
that shadow of war has microtransactions
in the form of loot chests war trust war
chests and XP boosts which include like
new skins for Italian as well as you can
also just like get specific orcs that
you would otherwise through the Nemesis
system from what we understand get orked
yeah people are people are mad about
this
because I don't know maybe it's because
shadow of Mordor did such a good job of
respecting your progress and you felt
like you were earning everything through
the nemesis ISM because the procedural
enemy generation stuff I don't know what
you guys think of this I think the the
the only real issue here that maybe
people are having a hard time put their
finger on is the fact that like the
items and the stuff that you're getting
through paying real world money that's
all stuff you can get in the game so the
fact that the game puts up this sort of
sign that's like by the way nothing
matters you can just throw money at it
that kind of robs people of feeling
invested in the fact that they're a part
of a journey and they will earn things
throughout that journey I think it's
really gonna come down to like how
pervasive it is like if they're in your
face you know shortly after the game
begins or like during cutscenes like you
know by now or like you could get this
thing or you know whatever if they're
super overt about it that's gonna suck
if it's somehow like tucked away to
where like you don't find it unless
you're looking for it
then who cares yeah it's a it's like a
fine line to walk I mean overwatch in
multiplayer games that have cosmetic
items and their loot crate's and
everything that's not as big a deal
because I mean it's randomized and
people you know the joking people like
joke about getting the same costed skins
over and over but it's still not like
you said it doesn't devalue the time
you're spending in it as much because
this actually apparently can unlock
abilities and stuff and this is a
narrative driven experience too I mean
you don't want you don't want to have if
you're trying to invest yourself in this
fantasy the last thing you want to do is
bring in you know real-world stuff I
don't think anyone really takes over
watches story or setting that's really
right I mean it's a means to play with
colorful characters that do wacky [ __ ]
in battle and get better at it that's
not quite this yeah is there something
to be said about I mean this is
single-player right yeah yeah I don't
like a loot system for for multiplayer
which I feel like most people have
allowed but I don't know I can't think
of any other game that's like well
because those are athletic those are
mainly aesthetic stuff and this is yeah
this is mainly like you can like pizza
you can expedite maybe four or five
hours here and there that you would
otherwise just spend in what would
otherwise be a really meaningful game
world in the single-player what I do
think about that what has me worried is
how that deal how that ties into any
sort of connectivity requirements for
this game because there are means out
there where you can legally hack your
PlayStation 4 save files to get things
like more are more level up this that
and the other so what's gonna happen
with this game in that sort of scenario
like what does it mean for the people
who made those products specifically I
think hyper can and explode or to those
yeah that's kind of weird
and people could if they really wanted
you to say screw you Warner Brothers
we're gonna do this our own way for free
that's it's strange it's straight I
don't know if it's damning but that's
really gonna depend on how it's
implemented
maybe the support comparison cally but
like imagine if you could just pay a
specific amount to get like Gjallarhorn
back in the day for destiny yeah that
devalue the time you spent grinding or
just enjoying the world like Pete said
yeah I think like I think people kind of
overreact at the word microtransactions
but I think the bigger issue is like
there by introducing micro transit
transactions into this kind of game
they're devaluing the game themselves
like I I mean it is just a game I like I
have to remember that and like I guess
if I if somebody if I found out like I
worked really hard for Gjallarhorn and
then somebody paid for it I'd be like
well that sucks and I put a lot of time
to that that I could have been spent
defending doing other things but I think
from the development standpoint you like
as a developer you're devaluing the
experience you're trying to create by
making it kind of like opt-in or you
could pay money to get mabu fala in
persona 5 and I groaned for like 20
hours for that [ __ ] yeah anyway so that
kind of Rose brought up some negative
reactions we do have a lot of on the
brighter side of things we have a lot of
shadow for gameplay up on our site which
looks pretty cool we got the chance to
go down and play it the other day in LA
Aaron Sampson did a few gameplay videos
I'm still really excited for that game
like you had said I'm hoping it's not
too like ubiquitous in the game those
microtransactions if they can be
tasteful about like maybe not on every
menu screen reminding me I mean even
that's kind of minor but just not having
it even hop on 35 seconds yeah if they
just want to leave it as like a little
link in the main menu
okay yeah anything beyond that is gonna
be yeah problematic I think because the
microtransactions for aesthetic stuff
can become great for people who really
love a game and have put in like
titanfall - for example you've spent
real-world money on Titan skins and
prime Titans but that's because you
already spent what like 300 hours in
that game not spending money and you
love that game enough to receive a value
personal value in buying those things
yeah you make that call right like if
you really like the game like it there
is something to be said I think you
could almost say the same for like
battlegrounds right like I don't know if
you are that invest into a game that's
all you're playing like kind of feels
does it feel nearly as bad right like
I'm like what got glad to give this
company this developer money for a hot
North Star skin then I'm very different
in this case yes yeah I'm thinking about
like splatoon which is something that
like I really care about the fashion in
that game like I want my clothes in that
game to like be stylish and also
functional for the way I play but Wow
gentleman was fast on the splatoon stuff
but like I like that I can't pay
real-world money for that because I
think part of the reason splatoon people
keep playing is to get money to get
better clothes and so I like I feel like
if they had introduced microtransactions
it would be the same thing of devaluing
the experience they're trying to create
there would be no loop it would just be
a a to being right which is I guess my
point with like regardless of whether
you're mad like other people are getting
something more easily than you are for
example like if you set that aside I
think it's just not a great design
decision yeah it also brings up the not
to be a conspiracy theorist but you
could imagine a world where the game was
either you know they didn't bother to
balance it properly or they balanced it
and ordinarily to encourage people to
just simply take the paid for route
because it could be one of those
scenarios where it's like alright I've
spent five hours I can't beat this boss
effort I'm gonna throw five bucks at the
game tomorrow right yeah I mean that
that would be bad and there's no reason
for us to expect or claim that that is
the case here but it's one of those
what-if scenarios that definitely makes
people say like
what is the point of this yeah what am I
getting out of this it's just weird that
developers are still doing this when
like microtransactions have become such
a bad buzzword like all these negative
connotations but I mean I think the news
originally came out of that preview
event someone in the menus that it
became a news story out of it like when
we went down to get gameplay and how I
and everything right and then some was
like oh there's microtransactions and
that was the big talking point which
that's gonna happen in flame reporters
are there and trying to tell people that
this will happen in the game when it
comes out of October 10th news to say we
do have gameplay up on the site and I
will be looking forward to that game
still hopefully they don't force that
stuff on us too much in the indie space
creators from spelunky and down will
announce the UFO 50 compilation yeah a
bunch of 8-bit kind of retro throwback
games yeah but it comes with like 50 of
them 2018 launch on PC so like Derek you
from spelunky again people who made down
well announced this Pete I imagine
you're pretty stoked about this I am
there's a good use case for this as well
a couple years back this Japanese show
called game center CX a pretty popular
they have a Japanese comedian who like
plays old video games and tries to like
beat them there's all these other
segments yeah and it inspired a couple
games on Nintendo DS and that those
games were comprised of reimagined you
know genre titles based on like 8-bit
stuff and those worked really well I
really liked how those came out so in
the hands of creators behind the games
of spunky and down well two games that
really do build off of that sort of you
know classic gaming experience I think
this sounds like it's in great hands go
fifty is a lot to tackle yeah at least
in terms of staying creative but maybe
this is a perfect exercise for people
who only release a game one every couple
years yeah to just really just like take
an idea give it a shot and see what
happens
so yeah I mean that's why just in the
gameplay it looks fun they look like
something I would love to have like a
like these bite-sized games I can play
like 20 minutes of one then try another
one out or maybe like it reminds me of
like having emulators back in the day or
anything like that so yeah like I said
it'll be 2018 launch on PC no specified
date yet so we'll have more on that but
you can go check that trailer out on
GameSpot if you're curious some of the
games look really fun
so going back to last weekend Callie I
know you part
paid in splatfest hmm one of the
grossest competitions I've ever been
witness to on social media so describe
what this is because I'm still a bit
hazy so there was also controversy here
and how it was set up in terms of the
competition right right so let's take it
from the beginning basically a splatfest
is an event where you pick a side in
this case it was mayonnaise versus
ketchup and you pick you pick which one
you prefer you say I think ketchup is
better I think mayonnaise is better and
you fight for that team and your wins
against the opposing team contribute to
you know that votes overall score and
then at the end of the team with the
most victories and the most points wins
and then it says like in this case team
Mayo won so it was Mayo is the best Mayo
is better than ketchup one of the gross
things is that in splatoon one red ink
and white ink were both things that did
not exist for obvious reasons mm-hmm oh
I saw some pretty good memes I did see
some some white ink or if you will
candy cane yes yes yes it was if
Nintendo was like all right here you go
you you're dang squid kids you know
there was also a lot of furry art for
some reason just like anthropomorphic
animals lots of weird stuff going on the
splatoon community but basically but
basically it was a Electoral College
popular vote situation where ketchup
overwhelmingly won the popular vote by I
think 73 percent of people voted for
ketchup because those people are correct
and and so a very small portion of
people voted for mayonnaise the problem
was only games against if you're a
ketchup player only games against Mayo
players mattered towards your victory
score so when we were playing we played
as a group of people from the office or
four of us doing like we had like fire
team going we're ready to battle we
played I think one game against an
actual mayo team all of our other games
were against ketchup and so the uproar
about this has been basically if I'm you
know if I vote for the popular thing I
have a lower chance of having a victory
against the unpopular thing and then the
counter-argument is well maybe the Mayo
players were just better and but at the
same time like a splatoon is is designed
I mean these are turf war battles so
you're just inking the turf and those
games are designed to be pretty balanced
and if you're playing against a team of
people who are relatively equal to you
in skill you can go either way I think
it's that's what's one of the cool
things and that's what keeps people
going back to turf war and so people
thought that was a little unfair that
like if I'm team ketchup I'm only gonna
play a couple games against Mayo and all
of the other victories I had during the
splatfest don't count so that was the
big upset and also Mays gross you're
they're both girls well condiments in
general obviously they should have done
like ketchup first mustard right right
let me won't be more obvious the thing
is that you have to consider this
Japanese game
no maybe I was a bit I normally
understandable but I would say is that
you know as someone who likes mayonnaise
on his sandwich but I don't go around
parading that I'm a huge advocate of
mayonnaise yeah that is it is gross mayo
is gross oh my goodness wait quick
interjection to defuse the tension that
I feel building a pecs penguin wants to
know what we're putting the mayonnaise
or ketchup on french fries hot dogs
ketchup it's contextual I so okay so I
the reason I said no Peter I'm very
sorry for doing that is because
splatfest historically what splatoon one
weren't always global so there were
Japan specific ones such a pan had I
think was milk tea versus something else
but like milk tea wouldn't be something
that would work necessarily in most
parts of the US for example this one
however
did happen to be global so the North
America Europe and Japan all had the
same categories which I thought was
weird and the other thing is Japanese
mayonnaise is way better
it's just he's like spicy it's dead it's
like kind of like sweet it's hard to
explain okay if you want to go the if
you want to say you mommy you can say
you mommy but it's not quite it's hard
to explain where it falls yeah but it's
different from American mayonnaise so
there are all those things to consider
but I think the main thing people are
upset about is that there should be a
better matchmaking system for these big
discrepancies in votes but I agree that
it was kind of a weird setup I would
have thought ketchup like if there it
was ketchup versus ranch I would have
gone ranch so hard I would have like I
would have had posters I would have like
campaigned in splatoon like made those
little posts you know we need is this
also versus guacamole yes good but what
if it's sour cream versus guacamole
marita spoon feeds himself sour cream
and you might think I'm joking but
you've seen him do it well just to prove
how much he likes sour cream he will eat
it with a spoon hey who wants to see how
much I like sir what have passed splat
FETs splat what have passed splat fests
been well though the one before was or
he was doing the where the pre-release
right he was the cake and ice cream one
cake and ice cream and that was another
case of ice cream had way more votes
what color I want cake and got stomped
on what cake is also bad I hate vs. pie
would have been a good one
see exactly but what do you color pie
brown well I didn't take him as an ice
cream vote I did not play a cake team I
didn't even get to play like yeah Oh
one of the drama's also is that of the
two idols there's pearl and marina
that's their the like the their
parallels to Callie and Marie holy crap
they're done that many yes coasters
versus waterslide
so I'm specific are they getting one of
my favorites was Autobots oh that's
really good
and then SpongeBob and Patrick oh that's
really good pokemon red versus blue no
competition blue past future circle
people have a warped perception of the
past why okay I want to know
marshmallows versus hot dogs is just
John strange well what's the reasoning
behind that I heard someone to clean I
want know okay I like campfire foods or
something Oh what are campfire for this
that was the third one
based on these dates that was August 7th
the first one was July 4th the third
time they ran out were like oh [ __ ]
campfire food and then they're like wait
we could do transformers no let's go
like high highbrow art science and then
modes of transportation pirates and
ninjas dope ninja samurai would be
better well pirates vs. ninjas is a it
dates back to the one piece versus
Naruto days oh so much wouldn't the
opposite of a plane be a submarine
Felipe I'd are said Gryffindor versus
Slytherin
Slytherin nah dude ravenclaw oh if I'm
choosing between Gryffindor Harry Potter
to know the truth also you're absolutely
I'm not a Slytherin okay so I'm saying
there's rice versus perfect body perfect
brain i I really love that loved one i I
just want to say that oh my god perfect
body one damn Oh for the perfect brain
usually does so this yeah so one of the
examples is milk tea versus lemon tea
obviously doesn't work but I think
something like book a I can't actually
read that very real and tsukkomi that
obviously people would be like what in
North America so I like blue
so yes there's some stuff s topics but
anyways the the thing I was gonna say
with pearl and marina is that so far the
thing with the most popular votes has
been marinas pick so that each pick one
in this flat has pearl who's like the
gremlin one that everyone hates she was
Pro mayonnaise and marina who's like the
Beyonce of splatoon and everyone loves
her she picked ketchup so everyone was
like ketchup so yeah but this did bring
about a lot of good maeín egg references
oh really
cute little thing so cute she calls it a
mayonnaise yeah recipe bellman oh I get
it
is that what you're saying oh like oh
yeah the rest of element one that makes
sense I didn't get it right away
actually so I didn't get it
thank you but now I get it he calls
what's her name peg right she's a hard
boiled egg she puts her mouth and she's
a entire conversation alright
valve announced a trading card game at
the International last night didn't also
didn't like the American favorite team
lose yes so basically a lot of the
American favorite dota 2 teams are out
there a lot of people like a lot of
people from North America their favorite
teams are out so like I think evil genie
I don't know I know like yeah evil
genius is out but they announced a game
and they were like new valve game and
everyone was like waiting and waiting
and then it said a dota card game yeah
and then there was a moment of people
going uh and then everyone clapped so
yeah you can watch that video if he
wants probably you've probably seen it
on Twitter if you're watching when
people just voice their disappointment
very loudly at the arena I think part of
it was because the trailer was was super
vague right it was like a big cinematic
so I'm like just to drop it you know and
what is this oh man what a teaser and
then it's
game yeah yeah yeah right here people
were like uh I totally expected
half-life 3 at an event I know right
mm-hmm
cool so let's move on to more pressing
games I guess you could say Mega Man
Legacy Collection 2 Mega Man 7 8 9 and
10 on ps4 Xbox one PC yep Pete you like
Mega Man games yep
I've only played Mega Man X Mega Man 2
and Mega Man 9 incidentally I really
like that game I like 9 to 10 a lot but
I don't know I don't know Mega Man well
enough to know what like 7 8 9 10 isn't
7 pretty derided in the Mega Man
community
thank you for disqualifying your own
opinion I was just about to do that 7 is
it's not my favorite it's not a lot of
people's favorite it's sort of this
weird like middle child thing happening
where it's like an awkward 16-bit
transition for the series which had done
quite well with Mega Man X already yeah
Mega Man X is is a great game for a lot
of reasons but yeah for me personally
megaman 8 is my highlight it's probably
one of the safer megaman games but it
was when the the 2d graphics sort of you
know took that extra leap forward and
looked cartoony but but crisp and
animated really well and stuff like that
Mega Man vanilla Mega Man had kind of
already run its course by the time they
got to 9 and 10 it was like well first
of all Capcom didn't make those it was
into creates and then it was like okay
how do we make old-school Mega Man
irrelevant again we just make it super
difficult I don't really like those
games so much I appreciate them then
they were soundtracks yeah yeah I put
them on I played a 90/10 on XBLA a while
ago yeah and that was maybe because I
felt like it was an excuse to play a
Mega Man game because they were relevant
again yeah maybe not that they were ever
irrelevant but I never beside from Mega
Man X which I played a ton back at its
nest days I didn't really play many of
them not gonna - I went back to get my
ass kicked
yeah those games are tough and it all
comes down to really understanding what
boss you face first so then you have the
right weapons to go throughout three
levels easier I think you know even if
Mega Man 9 and 10 aren't like incredible
games they really are a good sign of
like when a company listens to is
it's like okay we'll give you more of
what you want that doesn't happen very
often and so it's cool that it did at
all but this question also has a lot of
historical stuff to it like concept art
and that is one particular topic that
has been unraveling with a bit of
controversy of its own because in the
mega man 8 art section there's
apparently a piece of art that is not
from that game and it is like never
before seen like digital art of a
character that it's vaguely like Mega
Man but very different aesthetic and
design going on and people are sort of
like what is this from we've never seen
this in any game it doesn't match the
same art style as a tis as Capcom
subvert lis teasing a new Mega Man game
it is kind of close to the Battle
Network series which was like like
turn-based RPG type stuff on the Game
Boy Advance but no one really knows for
sure at Capcom isn't really saying
because they're not like putting a date
on it as far as like when this concept
art was right yeah I mean it's but it's
possible that it was even for a project
that was cancelled in the past I mean
like we have no we have no idea where it
is this is megaman 8 we're looking at
right now and so one of the other things
this collection does is it'll give you
little challenges in stages based on the
game they're like remixed in a way and
you have so much time to like complete
this new section or to you know perform
a task and those are those are
interesting ways to re-engage with with
some of these games what i really like
about the extra features beyond the
concept art again the soundtracks are
that you can hover over the boss concept
art and press one button to immediately
hop into that boss fight from any of the
included Megaman games which as a means
of like practice is really good because
Megaman games can be really tough and
you can get to a boss and not know how
to do anything and have to restart a
level after losing all your lives so
that's super handy and pretty neat sorry
what platform was Mega Man 8 on
PlayStation and Sega Saturn okay and
then night so there was there a pretty
huge gap between eight and nine because
nine was XBLA yeah it was like 97 I want
to say nine must have been what like two
thousand two thousand eight two thousand
eight okay yeah his name doesn't end for
nine and 10 a slight tangent but matter
fall from House Mark is coming out soon
August 15th yeah and I initially thought
it was a Metroidvania I think I might've
even said that not a lobby like a couple
months ago but it's more
mine's a Megaman maybe platformer action
game yeah I mean chiefly Megaman in like
yes 2d side-scrolling action with sort
of platforming stuff but you you pick up
little augments that change your
abilities
I like Megaman can I don't believe it's
the same structure where like you get
that stuff from bosses okay right I
believe you find them in the environment
from these civilians that you're trying
to free more or less depending if you
find certain ones you can then mix and
match these augments in different ways
for different effects cool megman Legacy
Collection two out now yep 20 bucks yes
for Xbox one PC yes sir sweet and like I
said if you are also into this type of
game maybe matter follow scraps attached
August 15 from house mark makers of
resogun the more recent next machina and
started a Super Stardust alienation an
alienation yet damn there they make a
lot of games they do but they're they're
usually tight I'm looking forward to
matter if I'll see what happens with
that in about a week that we'll talk
about that next episode in the lobby
releases a week from yesterday Yahoo's
Akua me
mmm-hmm the remake of the first Yakuza
game so the most recent one we talked
about was zero zero yes so this is just
a remake of the first game not just I
don't mean to be done not reducing it
god damn you I've never actually no I've
said this before in the lobby I've the
only a Yakuza game I've ever played was
the spin-off Dead Souls the only knock
his game I've ever played was the
real-life yeah cuz a game well all you
triads watching oh my god that'd be a
sick splatfest Yakuza vs. triad Bloods
vs. Crips oh no I'm just kidding anyways
dr. Q ami is sort of the second remake
of the first game it was sort of remade
for Wii and ps3 but yeah this it runs
off the same engine as got as a zero and
it's a direct continuation of that story
it's retconned a few things to allow
that to fit but by and large you are
sort of you know you've at the end of
the last game you put yourself in a
position where you ultimately end up in
prison and then you come back and you
have to deal with all these things that
are happening and you walk into Tokyo
and it's the exact well you know this
version of Tokyo it's the exact same
that you saw in yok is a zero like the
buildings are exactly where you left
them and all that so it feels like a
true sequel in a way that many we don't
get a lot of sequels like this that
really are just a direct continuation
you know there's and that that's pretty
rad I mean Yakuza has gone the story has
gone well beyond zero and kiwami at this
point the sixth game is out in Japan
which will be getting next year but for
US audiences I think the Yaak is a zero
was the first one that really kind of
got attention beyond it's a usual niche
audience so yeah if you liked that one
give it a shot if you haven't I'd
recommend it and then this would be a
great follow up and it's only thirty
bucks as well so it is a you know
potentially a budget release depending
on how you think about prices was there
maybe this is a conspiracy theorist kind
of thing do you think that Yakuza zero
and yakusoku ami being set in the same
version of Tokyo was like part of the
development cycle as well
like we can share these assets not even
assets like no yes it's the same stuff
cool yeah I don't think it's a bad thing
no it can be just recycle environments
well it's still got a story to tell I'm
just joking you sound a really positive
I need to bring you down no I'm just
joking oh you'll be playing that more
over the next few uh yeah weeks yeah we
should have a review of August 21st so
check that out damn that comes out
August 29th along with Mario Plus
Rabbids and some other game yeah cool
hell-blade sandwich sacrifice has made
video game news for a number of reasons
this week not the least of which is
because reviews are generally favorable
I'd say yeah Alessandro Phil are you
here at GameSpot reviewed you can go
check out his review on GameSpot he
liked it a lot
he thinks the game does some really
great stuff and I agree I beat it Sunday
night I'm playing through its it's weird
because looking at this this does not
you know the the definition of indie is
always kind of morphing it's not people
misuse it all the time but this is an
independent studio Ninja Theory who
previously the last thing they did was
the DMC remake was that the last thing
yeah before that heavenly sword they did
have
like character action combat games and I
think going into this a lot of people
thought they do the same thing but this
is more of a lot of people are saying
it's like a visual novel almost like
walking simulator ish with combat
elements and puzzle solving stuff mm-hmm
I thought the the visual novel not
comparison I guess that observation was
really interesting because like the
traditional idea of a visual novel is
usually like you know text on screen
character icon but I like bending that
definition a little bit and that's
definitely the vibe that I get starting
this game out I mean you're really like
I was listening very intently because I
didn't turn on subtitles I'm dumb and it
really captured my attention right from
the very beginning yeah I have a bunch
of questions about this but I do want to
Pete you're like maybe halfway through
based on what I saw you playing today oh
really I mean in six hours
no I little less than halfway you're
almost at the halfway mark so is it just
those those two paths sorry yeah now
that I think of it you're less than
halfway so you beat those two and that
is like halfway gotcha um yeah it's cool
cuz like you have and then you have
live-action stuff like this they have
really great they use Unreal Engine
actually back at GDC 2015 I think they
did a demo when I Tim Sweeney is that
correct epic scene yeah yeah he went on
stage and show off the actor for this
who actually was the video editor who
did a lot of their like video marketing
and in-game cutscene editing yeah Tamim
Antonio date and Tonio nah days I think
I'm correct pronouncing it correctly
he's at their studio in Cambridge he
they tapped her to help them out with
the facial capture and acting early on
the process telling her that she was
just a stand-in for that actor but they
actually were she was the actor and they
didn't really tell her until after but
she didn't awesome jobs they kept her on
so that is who you see doing all this
motion cap what's the value of that not
telling her well I'm sorry it wasn't
like the plan right away they just they
literally had her as a stand-in then
like huh this could go somewhere because
great job did awesome yeah um it's a
tough character to portray I mean oh
yeah
one of the other huge aspects of this
game is that ninja theory is pretty
upfront with the fact that they are
portraying this girl who has you know
what would he now call psychosis
although obviously this is uh I don't
even know what you want to call like
eight
ninth eighth century Celts although when
the Vikings came to Orkney which is
where this is the game is based off like
Orkney Celts Germanic tribes north of
like Hadrian's Wall in England when the
Vikings kind of took over that area the
Vikings became the prevalent tribes in
the ninth century so this is maybe even
like early ninth century this is all
kind of just like boring historical
stuff but it's kind of relevant because
she's a Celtic part of a celtic tribe
she's Celtic Warrior there's cinema but
the mythology that is kind of
paralleling her journey here is all
Norse yes or Odin Loki right here they
talk a lot about the the Northman which
I mean this is the kind of stuff that I
just can't get enough of so I was
already like so on board and then you
have that added aspect of what I think a
lot of people would interpret is
schizophrenia and they're very up for I
mean like even the opening credits has
like mental health advisory which so it
was like that blend of things is just so
cool to me you don't see that a lot yeah
there's a trigger warning to begin the
game saying a lot of this could be bad
stuff for people who potentially like I
mean I mean psychosis can be a symptom
of a lot of things to be a septum of
depression it could be a sense of
bipolar disorder like really really bad
anxiety but like you said I think what
she would have is the closest to what we
call schizophrenia today but ninja
theory was quote careful not to label it
right but which I appreciate yeah and
you see the puzzles here in the war in
the real world I actually want to
compare these puzzles to another game
but if I said that I would actually kind
of spoil the other game I don't i'm not
trying to be purposely illusive but i
don't know if you guys know what Kamath
talking about from last year so you're
doing these puzzles and part of the
coolest thing in my opinion and actually
goups you riot unofficial official game
spot number one fan he tweeted me today
for a question the lobby's saying are
you gonna talk about this games
portrayal of mental illness and i'm
we're doing a reboot hypersonic opens
episode I will say I think it's it's
really really authentic and empathetic
approach to portraying mental illness
they consulted a bunch people from
University of Cambridge psychiatrists
and like mental health experts I mean
they were like the first names in the
credits yeah yeah and like I said ready
for that trigger warning said you can go
to hell blade help dot info and I
thought it would be like a game
specifically for the game but it's them
just redirecting a bunch of different
people to international suicide hotlines
depression outlets and whatnot so they
took it very seriously and it shows so
you see combat right here people are
calling it there's a question about
whether it's Dark Souls we'll get into
that but you see her she's addressing
the camera they use binaural audio which
kind of it this game is best played with
headphones and you hear voices from
either side again that's part of her
psychosis you can hear voices
hallucinations are big but also the
delusion aspect of this game like people
with psychosis will start making
connections in the world that other
people see as coincidence and kind of be
paranoid about them in this game that's
how the puzzle come into play she sees
connections in the world that like
triggered this that it's kind of like
this hyper creativity and it's really I
think the game does a good job of
implementing that I feel I feel like two
minds about it because I think the idea
of finding those false connections and
making them seem real that's effective
but I'd like you saw me struggling with
one this morning I feel like it's in
certain cases drawn out to the point
where it's like hey I got it
yeah you don't need to be wasting my
time making me do this in ways where I'm
like folding in on myself trying to do
it well yeah you know so much of what
this game does is great in the immediacy
of how effective it can be that I feel
like those things kind of slowed me down
to the point where I was like I'm no
longer engaging with this character I'm
engaging with puzzle design and that's
not what for the most part this game
seems to be doing or at least that's not
where its strengths
sure but man like so I was playing in
that section you saw today and I noticed
these little glimmers of light like on a
on a tree and I thought oh that's weird
maybe that's like texture pop-in or
something like that yeah and they were
so fleeting they would like be there one
second and gone the next like when I
tried to actually focus on it when I did
actually get the chance to focus on it I
realized it was projected video of
eyeballs yeah really yeah so like it
looks like light because the pupil is so
big and there's only so much white of
the eye left on the video they're
projecting damn that it looks like
something like that but like even
details that you might not even
consciously be aware of are seeping into
your head it's just like its it's like
like you said there's something we said
you know apart from what they're trying
to do and depict with this character I
do think the puzzle solving can be
pretty drawn-out and dry after you get
it yeah I think they do push it too far
a little bit gameplay wise I like it
again it fits but it does kind of hurt
the pacing yeah
the combat as well later on there's a
few kind of mechanics that you can spam
I was showing or I was telling you about
it it's one of those things where once I
discovered one thing to do gets a
specific enemy I was like damn I wish I
didn't know this I don't know if it was
an oversight on their part but it's so
it becomes repetitive when you figure
these things out but we can get more
into the combat I think the combat is
satisfying and functional but I don't
necessarily think it's fantastic I think
it's functional like I would give that I
I mean like it's just so not the point
to me where I just kind of considered it
like I think the the most notable thing
about the combat is the environment in
which it takes place is really haunting
at least from what I've played it's
really disturbing and that imagery is
really effective and so the fact that
I'm just kind of spamming one thing is
is not really what I'm thinking about
anyway and I'm kind of glad for that
like I don't want to have to think too
hard about the combat because the other
thing about send you as a character is
that she's very she has so much fear in
her face when you see her and she's she
seems lost in a lot of ways and and I
think that's part of her character as
well that I think that the fact that I'm
just kind of like I swear is is almost
appropriate for her like I don't mind it
like I saw some people on Twitter kind
of being like the combat really turned
me off but I just don't like if you're
playing this game for the combat then I
think you're not your stuff is flying
over your head or you're not really
looking at the right things yeah
there didn't seem to be I have only
played probably like an hour two hours
but there was no like tutorial or
explanation of really anything right
right and it leaves some things you can
do up to you to discover beyond just
simply attacking and blocking like
combinations of inputs that you wouldn't
think of running yeah yeah
so no combos for sure yeah I feel like
the spamming is like a result of that
right like I'm I mean I'm in it I'm
gonna think of it I'm just gonna like
sorta that's mess around but like that's
nice to hear at least like along the way
you start realizing like okay combos
like yeah and even parrying and stuff
and like once you see that then it
almost that you know the combat then
falls into that sort of like puzzly sort
of engagement where you're looking for
towels and you're trying to react as
quickly as possible and that sort of
thing
yeah DFW gamer on YouTube was saying
someone else was asking you saying the
combat is kind of like a mix between God
of War and Dark Souls it's limited to
the small areas in which you fight
though I forgot to mention that you
don't you can't just always swing your
sword sign a wall will literally pull
her sword out at specific combat areas
right once you know she you've killed
everybody and you're done with that wave
of enemies or boss which he'll keep her
sword and then move on to the next kind
of story driven twenty minutes half hour
or puzzle-solving for the next twenty
minutes half hour I guess we could ask
that so okay
John Luke I'm sorry this is out of order
actually no no no okay I'll go an order
so Redfield on Twitter sorry I'm looking
at our run of show Redfield Twitter said
how would you best describe the overall
flow or feel of gameplay I know it's a
tired method but what contemporaries
does it most compared to so DFW gamer on
YouTube just mentioned the new god of
war I believe he means the upcoming one
and that's actually the first thing I
thought of they're going from that
third-person calm character action like
Devil May Cry almost that ninja theory
made to what the new god of war looks
like over the shoulder melee combat as
opposed to just free standing camera I
think that's an apt comparison I think
god of war looks like it might be a
little more in-depth but it does feel
weird because the camera is fixed over
her shoulder and you're fighting people
you're not like rotating the camera
sometimes anyway yeah yeah and the audio
figures in that because her voice will
say look out behind you that's really
cool too that's so cool unlike the fixed
camera also you always have a blind spot
with that like no matter what and I love
that because a lot of this game is about
perspective yeah what tunnel vision yeah
what you see and what you don't see and
I always feel slightly unsafe which I
like and it's it's definitely it was at
first I was like this is weird like I'm
not used at all
yeah and I sorry Rob oh one more thing
84 gesture X before it disappears off my
dad YouTube set I'm surprised no one's
mention Heavenly Sword yeah it's it's
similar but that was more like
definitely a cry like character action
right I didn't play it but yeah from
what I understand yeah it was not as
like focused is this game same developer
ninja theory and then people are
mentioning Chi from Heavenly Sword looks
a bit like narco I wonder if or sorry
Chi from Heavenly Sword looks a bit like
seonhwa wonder if it's like the whoa to
paintings like celtic tribes stuff you
were gonna say something yeah just on
the combat like i the little i played
yesterday a lot last night i had a
really hard time with this game like
among the you know the the the the take
on psychosis and like you know really
making you uncomfortable but like i had
a bug and like with the first combat
encounter that like you know probably if
not the most important encounter where
you're like kind of allowed or like you
have that freedom to kind of see what
the buttons do like oh my god the camera
got stuck in a fence like was blindly
doing [ __ ] and was stuck there for a
while like i think i even died there but
like i don't know there's something
about that moment we may be just like in
my own head with long with other voices
like yelling at me i don't know that was
really hard but i just had a lot like a
hard time getting into it and i it
people have been saying this like scheme
it's not for everyone i will continue to
play but it's just intense yeah it's
tough all the way through like i it's
just yeah it's alright it's hard to play
it's a hard game to explain like just
because it kind of it's also we'll get
more into like the triple-a vs india
pricing model stuff and also there's a
massive thing that I'm kind of hesitant
to bring up but I think it's in the
public eye enough that I'm not spoiling
anything anymore
yeah it's it's tricky because there's a
really good discussion we had with it
and we don't know if it's a legitimate
thing or not yeah yet essentially the
way I think we can say the game tells
you that permadeath is a thing yeah and
the way that it handles it is perhaps by
circumstance or what we can't talk about
it's right the beginning game so I think
we could talk about what the game is
telling you right like and what we
try it out yeah I mean essentially if so
you have this thing this this rot and if
you die enough times it will slowly
crawl up your body until it eventually
infects your brain and you're dead
wipe your save file whatever you say
according to this screen that comes up
it says send away will succumb to the
rot and all your progress will be lost
I'm assuming if you wanted to avoid that
you could upload the cloud it's the
power of the cloud yes Alessandra when
he was reviewing it just for like like
pragmatism was trying it out and he
didn't affect him he died he purposely
died like how many times like he was
like multiple times I'm saying he died
fine and there's and there's videos on
YouTube of people pushing it to like I
think 50 death yeah so I think it's in
public I enough we but then like Ninja
Theory saying no it's a thing I think
that's so pretty sure that's the truth
what I said that like PR responded to
someone he said like oh it's probably a
bug yeah
what I heard was that it's like there
are many different ways you can dungeons
in this game right and there are
different areas that can and cannot
facilitate to it so like there was one
area I won't tell you what I heard that
it's a it's a really tough area but it's
not it's just like a traversal aspect
yeah you can and you can die based on
fireman I fell off a branch yeah today I
think think about it like from a design
point like you wouldn't want to
implement that there in that you don't
want to discourage someone who just
can't get their mind around it right
potential potentially like initially but
I think this game takes enough risks
that I wouldn't be surprised if they
tell you do it anymore risk yeah yeah
this game they do a lot of things I mean
putting can we talk about putting
psychosis at the center of it in terms
of gameplay and the characterization of
being upfront about it is one thing but
and then you get into I mean yeah like
the guy who was dying he was dying in a
fight I did it 50 times right yeah but
so the right was growing up my arm but I
think it got to like my shoulder before
I finished cuz I was playing on the auto
difficulties got like a resonable for
--is-- auto scaling the better you do
the harder you'll get but then you can
also put easy medium hard or whatever I
do want to say like regardless of
whether it's true I think creating that
tension is cool like I think the idea of
the finality
of it and I mean talking about the
combat and how people have mixed
feelings about the combat I think part
of the my my impulse to spam was being
like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah and I
think that even if it's not true even if
the game is telling you this because I
mean this is an unreliable narrator
right this is a this is a story with
somebody who doesn't always see things
as they are
oh and here's voices that aren't there
and so I mean I think regardless of
whether it actually happens or not it's
a cool thing to introduce that
introduces another layer of tension
besides the voice in one ear and the
horrible chanting ahead of you
and the the you know dead bodies hanging
from trees let's it it creates another
dimension to it and I think I I mean I
know a lot people are mad about it for
some reason but I think it's it's
interesting irrational fear irrational
like dread and growing despair is huge
their character and it kind of makes you
feel that way too which is well I'm so
like courageous I mean even for if you
don't have something as Extreme as
psychosis like I'm just like day-to-day
anxiety is like just the feeling of
being like there's danger around the
corner like your body being like bit
beware and you're being like no body
there's no danger you're fine but what
if you died right now what if a stranger
wants to talk to you and has a question
and says hi what if something bad
happens so that's something bad
happening to me yeah and you're talking
to me even in the chair now the twitch
chat as we're really and says GameSpot
apparently you have to die in several
different places for the perma death to
work and then a bad player said perma
death was disproven so I don't it's it's
unclear and I think I'm that first
theory is curious to me but again that
would seem to not fall in line with what
the game is telling you mm-hmm I think
this is really interesting for ninja
theory because they're at a crossroads
where they can say all right guys
everyone thinks that this thing is one
lap Tyler yeah like they can either
confirm that they are as clever as
everyone thinks or say actually we
screwed up but thanks for thinking of us
and that the perma death
[Music]
yeah III I don't know if this is what
you're saying I would love for them to
just stick their guns back no it can
happen don't [ __ ] that's kind of what
I'm saying but they have to but if the
question posed to them is why does this
video why is there so much proof that it
doesn't happen yeah what did they say to
that yeah like it's either you're not
doing it right
which then I'd say then you didn't
explain it properly or it was a bug or
it doesn't happen or failure isn't that
what you think where it's all case study
very least like we're talking about it
now we have no idea so people playing
the game or like [ __ ] I don't know if is
gonna happen if I replay the game I'd
I'd still it would still even unless it
was completely disproven and they said
something I would still go into the game
if I replayed it and be like kind of
uneasy if I played on the hard happen to
me I think we could segue into the next
part of this topic which is the triple a
double a because I really want to talk
about how incredible this game looks
mm-hmm the production qualities are that
which we we don't see very often like I
often think of middle your solid 5 is
having some of the best character
modeling animation lighting and camera
work and scene composition out there for
games specifically because games are
sort of a bit behind Hollywood but this
takes things to a level that is so that
makes you feel such a personal
connection to the character and
everything is so unreal but real like
it's it's the lighting it's the texture
work it's the animations it's it's all
there and I can't think of another video
game that at the best moments of
hell-blade that looks as good as
hell-blade yes I will say that I
expected the dead bodies to be a little
have more detail it is about yes
affecting them a little too closely and
they looked kind of like the corpses
look like a like a ps2 HD upgrade for
some reason the corpses aren't they
don't look as good as everything else
but like oh my god just being in the
like the forest and like I was getting
distracted just looking around
well it's it's these moments - yeah like
this is the sort of thing where I like I
can't I is its CG right but I could you
could tell me it's not and I'd say wow
that was
good post proposed effect I mean and
they also have FMV I don't think I've
seen any yet myself but don't they ask
is that guy well guys fades in and talks
to you several characters later on you
combine that and there so like you know
alongside like effects and like you know
neat composition that it's not so Blaine
you know what I mean it's not like
here's a cutscene now oh yeah everything
is so seamless and consistent right like
there I don't think there are the only
loading times or if you like die hey
like I don't know it's
yeah and that's very important to the
experience of being on this journey with
someone like it's a very different beast
than shadow of war but the same thing
applies like if you're trying to invest
a character in this fantasy they need to
have as few barriers as possible to
engage with it and be a part of it and
this game for the most part ensures that
that's the case all the time it's it's
interesting that lawbreakers came out
the same day because oh no sorry to go
back to pricing stuff to play play like
$30.00 both $30.00 right and you know
like it's a six to eight hour game I
think I've been in about six hours felt
longer than that because of the
oppression of the story but I do think
that that's an interesting precedent
it's always like what are we why do we
price games $60 by default if like you
know it's gonna be this long or there's
gonna be this much to do or it's gonna
be you know this much replay value it's
always kind of this gray area and it
kind of hopefully sets an interesting
precedent for that conversation of the
future with these this level of
production in games no publisher would
have fun of this game sure I can't
imagine anyone brought this to it like
an EA or Warner Brothers and they'd be
like yeah we wanted a dark and brooding
pretty no examination what kind of deal
CD got planned for that like I know this
is exactly the [ __ ] I do like like this
game like you could have told me like
oak alley they made a game specifically
for you to enjoy right I'd be like oh
yeah sorry I'll give you some money for
that sorry nobody funded this like I
would believe you if you said like they
had a really hard time getting people to
want it because it just is it's so
specific but I
also so relatable it's I think there's a
sense of authorship even though you
couldn't credit it to maybe one person
or another but it feels like there's a
vision here that is just it's it's
allowed to do everything that the people
behind it want it to do and it reminds
me of something like the Last Guardian
in terms of that that feeling of playing
a game that is more than just a product
to sit on a shelf to sell the gamers and
write like this is in a sense of work of
art that that yeah is authoritative and
what it's trying to do absolutely John
Luke I am gonna jump or a skip over one
question go back to it sorry but I do
have a question in regards to this kind
of triple-a model luigi wagner who has
submitted a few questions a lobby
throughout the months we've been going
thank you very much could help blades
production models signal the birth of a
new tier of games as in smaller triple
A's that aren't constantly worrying
about action then we kind of covered
that but I think that is a very relevant
question for this game and it's one
that'll be examined on GameSpot we've
got something coming up cool oh yeah
yeah specifically about holiday right
and and this topic as well about
birthing a new category if you will cool
yeah
Luigi Wagner thank you again and then
I'm gonna go back to it one more
question kind of can I skipped over
about the combat Joseph Lee on Twitter
said thinking about buying hell-blade
but heard the combat is watered down
Souls repetitive and the big Pro is the
story thoughts uh I think Dark Souls is
just is a bad comparison I think that's
the kind of knee-jerk reaction to like
dodge and blocking based melee combat no
I think this is very different I mean
those those elements are there and maybe
like the fact that they don't tutorial
everything and you kind of figure out a
few things yourself that might factor
into the Dark Souls comparison yeah but
it's I mean there's someone who sucks at
dark souls I think I can sort of maybe
speak a little bit to the different
levels of challenge that exist like Dark
Souls is in a sense meant to be a game
that you you kind of need to like fail a
few times before you really understand
what it is you need to do and this game
yeah failure is pretty hard you don't
get punished for not being right the
first second or even third time yeah so
it's not as demanding and I think that's
really more the souls thing it's not
punishing it can be yeah Joseph Lee
thank you for your
question redfield Luigi Wagner as well
anything else in hell-blade before we go
on to lawbreakers yeah we're headphones
for sure yeah there were some freaky
moments in the best way where it's like
I think one the characters like talking
to you like from right here to left and
it just it felt like he was legitimately
pacing in the back of your head which is
literally what they did during the
recording sessions did you there's a
cool really cool feature on the main
menu of the game that you can lie the
binaural like audio capture device
literally is this black cylinder with
fake plastic ears on the side that
actually captures sound through the
contours of a human ear
oh yeah and pretty good like yeah lunge
at it and kind of circle it it's really
cool to watch yeah I missed that I
missed the trigger was just I was like
whoo corpses if I can give any practical
advice it'd be to sit close to a monitor
when you're playing it because having
the headphones then having just your
view only be this game not like on a
couch like 15 feet away I me being
having that right in front of my face
like a foot away also helped right that
would that I mean that could be
potentially date like I would yes VR
games must use similar audio or maybe
they well they use similar yeah there's
some games that use similar audio
techniques and VR is actually being used
at USC to treatment things like mental
illness and PTSD yeah so in effect like
stuff like this is bad but it can also
it's potentially bad when but when yes
when used with the proper direction very
effective yeah treating people one miner
know enough to get heavy but yeah this
game is super like with the psychosis
aspects and everything the trigger
warning is kind of essential at the
beginning it is a tough game to get
through especially if you've seen this
stuff up close all this stuff [ __ ]
sucks to deal with but I do strongly
advocate trying this game out because
it's a very empathetic and very
understanding and very you know frankly
authentic portrayal of this kind of
stuff and the fact that like this young
medium is doing it so well as opposed to
like you know you have movies like some
of my favorite ones dealer stuff silver
lines playbook punch-drunk love
melancholia that stuff all touches on it
but you know not just for a video game
but for any kind of entertainment or art
form
is a really really powerful portrayal
it's really nice to see something about
mental illness and some of my favorite
depictions or I wouldn't say favorite
but the the most important ones to me
have been in games but it's just nice to
see it not portrayed as being crazy
it's it is very empathetic and it's a
comic relief yeah there's no like ha
she's right Domon weird you know like
which does sometimes happen in other and
other stories about mental illness and
so it it's I mean exercise caution of
course if it's something that you think
will be difficult for you but I think
it's it's worth experiencing mm-hmm I
don't know if the audience can hear this
right now but you can there's a bunch of
I braiding and stuff happening is I'm
trying to bust through our walls
that's good segue to lawbreakers shake
and Babymakers violent Quakers anyway
like a rap artist was you know like we
were reporting Oh
ripping yeah yeah uh lawbreakers I
almost did that goddamn transition that
you called me out for oh cool lob
records on my game today lawbreakers did
it again lawbreakers Rob you me and Jake
were playing a lot of yesterday I played
a little man this morning of you Callie
or Pete you got the chance to play much
no this game I want to play I am getting
my butt kicked in this game as it's not
like people comparing to overwatch and I
know IVs I see why because it's kind of
character driven specific abilities for
each class but then I would say half of
the game is kind of that half is just
this Unreal Tournament quake the
fast-paced very high skill I almost had
ceilings skill floor learning curve kind
of it's I think it's tailor-made for PC
audiences with a twit and mouse twitch
shooting but I'm apparently the ps4
version has had issues anyway oh really
long songs yeah yeah yeah I'm interested
to see how that plays on on controller
yeah you don't know about that but
had an issue where it's been like
hitching for like half a second oh and
boss boskie was saying like oh that
should only happen if you're like
changing roles or like exiting in menu
and people are like I know it happens
like literally any time that's a pretty
huge oh not over sight that's a pretty
huge problem to have it's probably
shooter it sounds like it's gonna be
patched today ok cool
mostly about that cuz this game I'm
having I'm actually it's tough there's
eight classes it's over watch it was a
very good game for people who don't
always play like PC shooters to get into
which you know like I had taken a lot of
time off from this that kind of stuff
overwatch has it started with what I
might be wrong 21 characters now it has
25 21 because then they added honor
Orissa sorry Sombra and doom fest but
that game had someone for everyone and
that was kind of the point right to be
inclusive both in terms of
characterization and just the abilities
to kind of suit and this game kind of
does but even the lower-class like the
enforcer is kind of soldier 76 I got to
stop with the overwatch comparisons he's
kind of started to call of the the
vanilla shooter kind of introduction
with an assault rifle sprint grenade but
then I start playing this right here is
the rate nope Vanguard thank our thank
you but it says yeah they're eight
classes the different character for each
one to portray the law or the break is
they I start playing the juggernaut
which like a shotgun defensive class my
one recommendation if you're not if
you're learning this game and you're not
just inherently good at PC shooters if
you're like me if you're not good as I
am not good sorry I just I wasn't
bragging that was that was a
self-deprecating and I miss worded it
try out like learn what you can do to
get better because I was playing the
juggernaut and instead of trying to do
what everybody else was doing you get
the ball to bring it to the enemy base
or capture this zone and be really good
at offense I just hung back and play
defense and it's much more fun it ease
me into it I had a class that you know
kind of was suited to my abilities more
learn what class works for you and start
playing with that to ease yourself into
it cuz this game there are a lot of good
players already and and I suck them but
it's it's tough I would say like for me
like I feel like I was I was decent
enough at like PC you know mouse and
keyboard shooters but it's the mobility
factor here where you cannot stay put
ever
yeah like there is no role really where
you're like stationary like it and even
when you're playing with these highly
mobile guys like you can just get worked
if you're not you know especially 0g
moments right like you are which are
great like really it design was it is
really fun though I I think this game is
fun i I have good and bad matches all
time and I think one of the of a few
gripes I have is like I wish you could
pick the game mode all right to register
it
yeah the match type it's just quick play
or no just get lost into I know you
there's custom matches I just checked
today custom masters that you create
yourself or no no no there's there's
quick matches and then you can pick like
Oh play or you can isolate you're like
the servers that's foreign I'll look it
up while you're talking but I couldn't
good over guard but yeah yeah I think
it's what I find your character like I
know but what I got to Harrier which is
I guess apparently then the newest one
that we seen well it was so the Alpha
and the beta originally had like three
or four and they at tape we got to play
more but Harry area is it yeah and like
was when really well with that character
and and is it's now my favorite but yeah
I don't know it is tough I think PC PC
runs and looks great by the way I was
getting like ultra settings solid 80
frames per second like consistently on
like a 1080 mmm-hmm but I don't know
where my exactly up I like this I like
this game I actually didn't think I
would and I I'm definitely gonna play
some more of it to be honest like
Vanguard flying around it's just one of
those things to with like we you
compared like overwatch all the time
right like that's where you're always
near with your alts and all these things
but I know for me at least I kind of
fell off the overwatch train so it's
kind of neat to like maybe try something
else out these matches are quicker than
overwatch matches as well
the majority of overwatch matches I
I think my biggest hesitation with
starting this game is that I get really
nervous with like stuff that's you know
it's multiplayer online pretty much only
is like you're learning in real time
what and other people can see your
failures and that was a great timing for
that death I that's my biggest
hesitation I think and I like I've said
this before I think like on paper I
should really like this game and I want
to play it but I'm also like if people
are already good at it I'm just afraid
to disappoint a team is the biggest
thing and I just from what you guys are
saying it sounds like that's really it's
really hard to to learn to be good at it
like fielding takes a lot of failure and
other people have to bear the brunt of
that I guess yeah does that process feel
like it's any better due to the the sort
of speed of everything cuz when I used
to play like Unreal Tournament 2003 for
example like way back in the day I got
my ass kicked all the time but it was
the idea that like I could get back up
so fast and get right back into the
action that the loss almost didn't
really feel that bad to me
okay sure I'm not succeeding but I'm
also still playing like seconds later
this is just such a dumb stupid metaphor
but I'm gonna go for it anyways yes
imagine you're playing Little League
baseball and you get accustomed to the
speed of the pitch and you're smoking it
out of the park every time yeah and then
all of a sudden you're playing in a
major league game and they're pitching
so you're pitching so fat they're
pitching so fast that you're swinging
like two seconds too early that was my
experience of this game I came in this
game was like it was so fast and hard to
comprehend it was so fast maybe not hard
to comprehend but I was overcompensating
and just missing and freaking out every
time someone came up to fight me when I
actually got a sense of the pace of game
after like 10 matches or so slowed down
a little bit to kind of really figure
out was going on what could I do to help
the objective it started clicking and I
started getting kill streaks and I
started learning how to use my abilities
as I was telling you the juggernauts my
favorite class right now he's got like
the shotgun with a blade on it for a
melee attack and then you got like a may
ice wall kind of a holographic hologram
wall thing that say they're trying to
carry the ball into your base it's like
the bomb and this if you played a halo
you I put a wall up in this hallway
they're stuck two other guys came from
behind them and killed them and we
defended the base when you start to kind
of slow down and you start thinking
rather than just reacting to everything
that's going on and making use your
character becomes really fun that this
is this right here was mine not just
kidding this is Rob this is Rob playing
the Harrier class kind of a sorry a
weapon with an ion from titanfall to alt
man yeah it's do they call them alts in
this game I don't know if they have a
name for it it's just the third ability
that's mapped to cue that unlocks alts
what else perks perks or abilities Oh
titanfall that's your joke more I would
say like where I was enjoying it was
when I finally got a character and got
my role like you know they're all kind
of support class like healers like once
you figure that out you just yeah you
just need to like really spend a lot of
time I would say with one character and
then it started clicking for me as well
as like oh like don't don't get caught
in like sometimes you just find yourself
like doing you're playing dumb like why
am I like on their side of like the map
or like why don't I back off and not
chase some guy like into a room play
defense for a while yeah
like honestly yeah because because of
what is intimidating is definitely like
you know you're figuring out these
characters you're freeing out the map
and like actually not from most part how
to play the game but like the game modes
like you know unless you're like looking
through all the tutorials which could
take like maybe an hour to understand
like each one of these game modes cuz
they're kind of different and you know
they have all new names like uplink and
overcharge I feel like that was kind
emitting just getting thrown into that
like okay what am i doing yeah but the
more I play it the more I was like
catching on and actually enjoying it
rockfish 100 on Twitch said I'll go
download it's free to play anyway it's
$30 don't don't think it's free I'm
assuming there's going to be a change
there I'm assuming the screen will tell
you it's $30 but I just wanted to
clarify
anything else on lawbreakers I think the
map design is great the zero-g areas at
sufficiently cool verticality that's
what I was wanting infinite warfare to
do with its multiplayer the zero-g
environment but this games fun I don't
know how much longer I'll play it I
don't again this has so much of a
learning curve that I wish I had more
time to just devote to this game because
it is a great palate cleanser after
playing hell-blade and maybe like
getting back in I'm also kind of
typically getting back into overwatch
with the summer game skins and Lucille
Ball everybody's been hearing Lucille
Ball especially because they're making
that Lucille Ball movie with Cate
Blanchett yeah so this game here Lucy
this game is uh it's fun we will have
the full review of her from Miguel
concepción he's been playing yeah sure
it should be a buddy in this week cool
yeah sweet that's our show
I don't think Shiva announced it yet but
our giveaway is 25 PC codes and 25 ps4
codes for hell-blade Senna was
sacrifices one person gets all 50k ya
know if you don't again if you don't
follow GameSpot on Twitter go do so and
then retweet the tweet that she was
about to put up I think this week we're
gonna wait until Sunday to pick the
winner it'll be random so just retweet
it we will pick them and if you enjoyed
our conversation or that intrigued you
about this game highly encourage you to
check it out like Rob you said I don't
think everyone will love it but I would
definitely tell everyone to try it see
what it see what it's all about that is
pretty much it anything else
what are you playing this week you've
been playing matter fall a little bit
matter fall probably a little more
hell-blade kiwami there's a couple of
women in games there's a couple other I
am somewhat inundated with games right
now there's a lot of things happening
over the next couple of weeks that have
made it a little bit hard to okay yeah
sorry less games sorry I didn't mean
just kind of one more thing Pete the PC
giveaway is worldwide so it's not
confined to US or Europe the ps4
giveaway is US or Europe only apologies
if you are on ps4 outside of those
territories sweet BAM
Rob what are you playing ah
you'll play a little more lawbreakers
and if I have a good moment tonight
where I can sit down with a nice cup of
tea and dive into hell-blade oh I
thought you're gonna say titanfall they
could take an ambien and just fall it's
kind of a bummer that they're as of now
they're not going to release any more
updates so we can't but they had a great
run yeah
don't be they'll be patching in stuff
though poor boys just that it may be
titanfall 3 will be announced you know
down the I'm sure I don't know it stuff
down the river down the road sorry the
game didn't sell as well as I would have
loved it was a tough was it going up
against battlefield 1 Call of Duty was
like the week after two weeks after that
window hopefully more people play they
get although it has increased apparently
since release that co-op mode is fun
[Music]
what else do you want to set tomorrow
Peter and I are screaming yeah yes
they're right what are we screaming
tomorrow I thought you do weird we play
in Zelda where you're gonna get your ass
handed to you no we're gonna play you a
cassette no man what are we playing
it's my Triforce what mayhem playing
agents of mayhem that's I did not know I
could do this with my hand look at that
Triforce I did not know pretty sure we
are I'm pretty sure that's why yeah yeah
and then I can't what you playing I'm
still playing splatoon I just kind of
play a couple of games and when I get
home I'll probably be playing catch up
on some games so like as I was saying
didn't really work Nyssa tried trying to
finish some games that I have not yet
finished oh and I before the giveaway
ends I need to get shiny type of cocoa
in Pokemon Sun and Moon because I need
him for my competitive team shiny what
shiny top of cocoa
it's a pseudo legendary that is very
popular on competitive teams and with
the competitive team that I want to roll
with I want to be able to like because
I'm going to the Pokemon world
championships to cover it and just see
and to watch the games because that's
what I like to do and I want to be able
to play like there's like pickup games
basically yeah so I want to have my team
ready to go before I leave sick so I
will be bring out my 3ds again and doing
some soft resetting to try to get one
with good stats top of coke awesome it's
gonna take hours probably guess what I'm
playing guess what I just got
preview code for their score get to talk
about Sam lets rule out of the Mike dude
okay sorry X quacks calm - were the
chosen I get to we'll have a preview up
next week Thursday so I'll be playing
that and yeah I'm reboot we talking
about hell-blade more and I'm sure gonna
have a whole lobby episode about it -
all right no it's the embargoes Thursday
after the lobby well they're pushing the
lobby to Thursday next week I'm kidding
no we're not we'll be back same time as
always 11 a.m. here at San Francisco
Wednesday Pacific time thank you for
stopping by again go retweet that
giveaway tweet if you want a chance to
win a PC or ps4 code for hell-blade
we'll see you next week
agents of mayhem tomorrow at 11 a.m.
stop plugging stuff I hope you're right
we're done
[Music]